noch fünf tage und dann können sie
wieder abgehängt werden all die vielen
plakate die uns ein besseres deutschland
versprechen bis zur letzten minute wird
um jede stimme gekämpft
denn noch immer wissen viele bürgerinnen
und bürger nicht wo sie ihr kreuz machen
sollen viele haben aber auch schon
gewählt per briefwahl kampf in corona
zeiten und frau merkel die spielt gar
nicht mehr mit in diesem jahr ist vieles
anders 3 die ins kanzleramt wollen und
gefühlt wird jeder schritt live
gestreamt rielle bürgerdialoge unzählige
interviews und jede menge umfragen
bleiben die inhalte da auf der strecke
die aufgeregte republik wahlkampf 2021
unser thema heute in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
schönen guten abend ganz herzlich
willkommen aus berlin in diesen zeiten
sind ja umfragen eigentlich die
wichtigste währung und deshalb freue ich
mich über den besuch von gianina mütze
sind sie ist mitgründerin und
geschäftsführerin von siena das ist
eines der führenden unternehmen für
digitale markt und meinungsforschung
auch schon guten abend und ich begrüße
kerstin münstermann sie ist leiterin des
hauptstadtbüros der rheinischen post und
natürlich jetzt auch heftig im stress
zugeschaltet ist uns frank
brettschneider er ist professor für
kommunikationswissenschaft an der
universität hohenheim schönen guten
abend herr bretschneider und ich und ich
begrüße stephan lamby er ist
dokumentarfilmer und gestern lief in der
ard seine beobachtung der drei
kanzlerkandidaten wege zum macht hieß
der film und zehn monate lang hat er
armin laschet annalena baerbock und olaf
scholz begleitet guten abend herr llambi
haben wie was ist denn jetzt nach dieser
ganzen zeit die sie die beobachtet haben
was würden sie sagen was ist so richtig
typisch für diesen wahlkampf in diesem
jahr
ist der erste wahlkampf und der korona
bedingung die erste wahlkampf ohne
angela merkel seit ewigkeiten gefühlten
ewigkeiten und ein wahlkampf der gleich
sich ausführlicher darüber sprechen der
mal wieder
sich nicht einen großen
themenorientierte sondern an
nebensächlichkeiten muss ich viel zu
lange aufgegeben hat
also für mich ein wahlkampf der
vergebenen chance nein ich muss so hart
sagen sehr enttäuschender wahlkampf ok
klare worte von ihnen kommen zusammen
sind sie herrn llambi das zustimmend ist
eben ungewöhnliche zeit in diesen corona
zeiten also was ist für sie so das
typische an diesem wahlkampf die haben
ja auch schon viele beobachtet ja ich
würde eigentlich ihnen zustimmen denn
wir haben corona pandemie wir haben die
klimakrise die ja in diesem sommer
selbst in deutschland so sichtbar wurde
wie nie zuvor wir haben afghanistan ein
internationales desaster und wir reden
wenig über diese themen ich finde in den
letzten wochen kam es ein bisschen durch
aber im frühsommer sprachen wir über
bücher lacher
vergeigte chancen wenn ich es mal so wir
sagen darf und
jetzt auf den letzten metern versucht
jeder vielleicht auch noch mal sich am
riemen zu reißen auch die kandidaten und
die kandidatin selbst herr bretschneider
wie haben sie diesen wahlkampf
wahrgenommen der natürlich auch anders
stattfinden musste unter anderem wegen
der chor ohne bedingungen aber jetzt
kommen ja noch mal auch die richtige
wahlkampf kundgebungen gerade jetzt am
kommenden wochenende
ja und die wahlkampfkundgebung wir
werden schon auch wahrgenommen ich finde
was anderes bezeichnet in dem wahlkampf
nämlich diesen kometenhaften aufstieg
der spd das hätte niemand für möglich
gehalten und dass sie auf einmal wieder
mitspielt und sogar vorne liegt ist
total unerwartet und das etwas zu tun
damit das gleich zwei parteien die cdu
und die grünen so unglaublich viele
fehler gemacht haben ich habe noch nie
so viele fehler in einem wahlkampf auf
einmal gesehen wie in dieser wahl und
das hat es letztendlich wieder spannend
gemacht war natürlich interessant weil
auch ein schuss stand ja auch dem wurden
ja auch dinge vorgeworfen frau müsse
aber man hat vor allen dingen auf die
fehler von herrn laschet und frau frau
baerbock geschaut was fanden sie am
typischen und wie erklären sie sich dass
so viele wähler noch unentschieden sind
die er vielleicht hängt das damit
zusammen dass alle noch auf den
wahlkampf warten dann ist sehr in der
tat so dass wir sehr wenig über themen
gesprochen haben 72 prozent der
deutschen wünschen sich mehr inhaltliche
auseinandersetzung zu beginn des
wahlkampfes hatten sie die
erwartungshaltung dass man über
klimaschutz umwelt politik viel sprechen
wird im wahlkampf sie haben sich
gewünscht dass man über soziale
gerechtigkeit rentenpolitik wirtschaft
spricht das ist für sie persönlich das
wichtigste thema aber all das ist
eigentlich nicht passiert wir haben es
ja schon hinrunde erwähnt es wurde viel
über kandidaten gesprochen
es ist ein sehr personenbezogener
wahlkampf und das ist wie schon gesagt
ein sehr unglücklicher wahlkampf
es sind wirklich viele handwerkliche
fehler passiert und das wird vielleicht
auch dazu dass man letztlich noch etwas
verhalten zeigt an der ein oder anderen
städte und fraumünster wenn bei der
berechnung der gerade den aufstieg der
spd
ansprach ist das kann herr scholz so
punkten so willst du den umfragen weil
die anderen eben so viele fehler machen
ganz klares ja also herr scholz macht
ihr eigentlich keinen wahlkampf sondern
der nach die raute und sagt ich bin ja
in der regierung und stehe für solides
regieren dann hat er noch ein stichwort
nämlich gerechtigkeit das und den
mindestlohn das sind zwar glaube ich
zwei ganz gute plakative dinge die sich
die spd sich hat einfallen lassen und er
sagt es berührt ihn wenn ihnen die
menschen gut finden dass kommt glaube
ich in jedem wahlkampf kundgebung der
firmen verfolgen nein die stärke der spd
das ist für die union glaube ich so hart
ist wirklich die schwäche der union also
dass man sich das narrativ der guten
soliden regierungsarbeit einfach mal so
abnehmen lässt ich beobachte die union
schon sehr lange ich finde das
faszinierend und für die union wirklich
desaströs und das armenische das hat
geschehen lassen ist glaube ich das was
ihm auch die eigenen leute so ankreiden
also es sind einfach viele viele fehler
gemacht worden in seiner darstellung er
hat vielleicht laufen lassen ich glaube
sein team war nicht gut genug
aufgestellt um nrw zu regieren und
gleichzeitig kanzlerkandidat im bund zu
sein somit ist das ein schlechter
wahlkampf der sich dadurch aussieht also
nehmen die menschen das war wenn sie
bürger befragen nach ihren präferenzen
oder ist es die sache der
zerstrittenheit die die leute stört also
warum hat armin laschet solche
schlechten werte er ist fängt vielleicht
beim werde frage strategie an der
kandidat wurde ja nicht groß gekürt
sondern kam auch gleich aus sicht der
bürgerinnen und bürger ein bisschen
holterdiepolter daneben in die position
des kanzlerkandidaten und es gab keine
erkennbare strategie die die deutschen
im zuordnen konnten die sie der union
zuordnen konnten es blieb eine lehre und
wir sehen das immer sehr stark indem
kompetenz vergleich oder wenn wir die
menschen nach den ihnen zugeschriebenen
charaktereigenschaften des
spitzenkandidaten fragen da kommt armin
laschet immer so etwas im weg als der
mann ohne eigenschaften man weiß gar
nicht wofür er eigentlich steht über
doping der humor zugeordnet aber diese
vermeintlichen kanzler fähigkeiten wie
führungsstärke inhaltliche stärke in den
themen das sieht man einfach sehr
deutlich er es wird eher olaf scholz
zugeschrieben und deshalb funktion
dieser kandidaten wahlkampf der spd auch
so gut aber oder scholz ist dann auch
wieder derjenige der alles so an sich
abprallen lässt eigentlich herr llambi
sie haben in ihrem film wege zu machte
er gestern lief die am donnerstag auch
bei phoenix dann nochmal hier läuft da
sieht man auch eine interview mit olaf
scholz noch mehr will dann einfach keine
richtige antwort geben aber eben
verzeiht man das wie haben sie das
empfunden
also zunächst einmal olaf scholz und die
spd die haben ein unglaublich großes
glück in den letzten wochen weil die
fehler der union und der grünen also die
zentren kandidaten die versteht man
sofort das lachen das von lasse das ist
unangemessen war versteht man die
kopierten oder abgeschriebenen
buchseiten von vw aber auch die kann man
gegeneinander halten versteht man sofort
die affären in die olaf scholz
verstrickt ist oder die eben angehängt
werden so muss man es mindestens sagen
versteht kein mensch und das ist ein
erheblicher unterschied auf die letzten
meter dafür braucht man
untersuchungsausschuss dafür braucht man
gutachten dafür braucht man juristen die
das prüfen prozesse also das ist einfach
viel zu kompliziert insofern die natur
dieser erklärung ist einfach völlig
unterschiedlich aber die tür das schiff
sozusagen
ja einfach so sachen nicht an sich
rankommen lassen dann dadurch angreifbar
er beherrscht einem eine fähigkeit die
man möglicherweise haben muss für dieses
mächtigste amt in deutschland und auch
in europa nämlich gefühle an und
abzuschalten wenn es denn notwendig ist
für ein politisches ziel also ich habe
ihm
eine harmlose frage gestellt ob er einen
umstrittenen wahlkampfspot der spd
kannte bevor der einmal gezeigt wurde
und die frage bei dem unangenehmen und
er antwortet nicht mit ja oder nein
sondern ausweichend ich stelle die frage
noch mal wieder eine ausweichende
antwort und das ging achtmal über fünf
minuten wir haben das in dem film nur
eine gute minute
eingeschnitten das war ein bisschen
absurdes theater
dann kann man sagen das ist kein
angenehmes interview verhalten niemanden
der bundeskanzler werden will man kann
das auch genau andersherum deuten diese
abgebrühtheit einer hartnäckigen frage
die wiederholt kommt nicht zu antworten
ist vielleicht ein besonderer ausweis
von professionalität
ich fand es in der situation ehrlich zu
sein eher unangenehm dann wurde er in
diesem wahlkampf unglaublich viel
kommuniziert also es gab drei große
debatten es gibt wird auch noch eine
debatte mit allen spitzenkandidaten
geben es gab bürgerdialoge ganz viele
zeitungen haben auch alle drei
kandidaten interview herr bretschneider
wurde letztendlich zu viel kommuniziert
das dann dass man gar nicht mehr
eigentlich wusste auf was man sich
konzentrieren sollte in diesem wahlkampf
war das feuer glaube ich ja doch noch
mehr als wir es sonst gewohnt waren
würde ich nicht sagen das ist so die
sichtweise der politprofi beobachter wie
wir das sind für uns wird es dann
irgendwann zu viel weil wir denken das
haben wir alles schon gesehen und alles
schon gehört und das gibt nichts neues
dabei viele wählerinnen und wähler
fangen erst drei vier wochen vor der
wahl an sich mit der wahl intensiv zu
beschäftigen einige auch erst jetzt auf
den letzten metern in der letzten woche
und für die sind diese sendung völlig in
ordnung gehören sich dann auch nicht
drei träger an oder gucken sich das an
sondern 1 und das kann ihnen hinweise
gegeben im augenblick sind viele
wählerinnen und wähler noch auf der
suche sie wissen nicht so genau ist für
sie wesentliche der kanzlerkandidat die
kanzlerkandidaten oder ist es die
parteien die programmatik oder sind es
die möglichen koalitionen nach der wahl
und je nachdem was gerade in ihrem kopf
im augenblick den ausschlag gibt
tendieren sie in die eine oder andere
richtung denken sie eher an die
kanzlerkandidaten läuft das zugunsten
der spd denken sie eher an die koalition
und ein rot grün rot dann läuft es eher
zugunsten der cdu und das ist das
besondere bei dieser wahl und dass da
menschen immer noch auch viele
informationssendungen nutzen kann man
schon behaupten warum wisse wie viele
menschen sind denn wirklich noch
unentschlossen das sind ja eine ganze
menge glaube ich bin nicht richtig habe
und wie viele wollen denn eigentlich
gerne wirklich inhalte haben
also inhalte wünscht sich wirklich die
große mehrheit
72 messen wir die sagen sie brauchen
mehr inhalt im wahlkampf
wir haben auch schon ein bisschen früher
im wahlkampf gemessen oder
herausgefunden dass die menschen sich
auch weniger eine negative campaigning
wünschen also weniger
schlammschlachten gleicht locker
übersetzt aktuell sieht es so aus wir
haben ein recht hohen briefwähler anteil
in diesem jahr auch bedingt durch corona
gleichzeitig haben wir aber auch einen
anteil an menschen die heute noch nicht
wissen wen sie wählen würden und das
sind unter denjenigen die sagen dass sie
sicher wählen in unseren messungen circa
15 noch unter wenigen glücklich sicher
sind dass sie wählen werden also da ist
schon noch spielraum gleichzeitig sehen
wir aber dass sich auf den
sonntagsfragen wien die bewegung nimmt
ab also auch da kann schon sein dass ein
gewisser gewisser satz auch schon
zementiert ist sie werden auch noch
weitere umfragen machen jetzt auch in
dieser woche noch immer wieder am
donnerstag vor der wahl letzte
sonntagsfrage veröffentlichen
wahrscheinlich am donnerstagmittag und
dann werden auch wieder da kurz vorher
werden wir auch nicht machen
haben diese umfragen und wie sehr sind
sie auch als als zeitungen dann dass sie
sagen da müssen wir drauf gucken und das
beeinflusst auch unser verhalten wen wir
da mehr aufmerksamkeit geben ich glaube
die haben sehr großen einfluss die
umfragen und ich bin mir immer nicht so
ganz sicher wie gesund das eigentlich
ist auch für für diese ganze debatte vor
der wahl natürlich wenn auf einmal die
union und bei einem institut unter 20
fällt dann kommt das bei anmeldung dann
ist alarm und da möchte ich uns gar
nicht ausnehmen dann gucken auch wir und
berichten darüber
versuchen den hintergrund zu erklären
und so weiter also diese umfragen die ja
ich weiß nicht wie viele institute
gefühlte sind das acht mittlerweile ich
glaube es sind weniger aber die die
relevanz sind sind ja fast täglich mit
neuen zahlen auf dem markt interessant
aber und vielleicht kann man das dann so
abbinden ist ja doch das meistens der
trend relativ ähnlich ist also so dass
man irgendwann schon denkt wenn ich ein
querschnitt nehme über die woche habe
ich zumindest eine ahnung
wobei ich glaube sachsen anhalt war es
im sommer lagen die umfrage steht ute
nicht gut für herrn haseloff den
amtsinhaber der ging am ende viel besser
raus das ist auch das was man sich jetzt
bei der union so erzählt dass man sagt
ja
mal gucken wir haben da noch spielraum
das ist eine hoffnung aber ich fand
interessant was sie sagten zu negativ
kampagnen das erklärt glaube ich auch
ein bisschen die stärke der spd noch mal
denn sowohl die grünen die waren zwar
sehr harmonisch in ihrer
kandidatenfindung dennoch hat der
geneigte zuschauer und leser doch
gemerkt dass es zwischen annalena
baerbock und robert habeck dann doch
nicht ganz so harmonisch zuging im
vorfeld nicht vor allen dingen dahinter
nicht er konnte seine enttäuschung am
ende doch nicht verbergen und bei der
union gab es einen machtkampf
sondergleichen und dass das nicht
goutiert wird gerade bei den
unionswählern hätte die union eigentlich
wissen können denn das war schon 2018
mit dem kampf zwischen cdu und csu auch
das kam nicht gut an umso interessanter
dass man es nicht schafft es im januar
zu sagen wir haben einen neuen
vorsitzenden der cdu und der hat ein
konzept wie er denn die
kanzlerkandidatur für sich beanspruchen
möchte herr brett leider sehen sie noch
eine möglichkeit jetzt wirklich
wahlkampf so zu machen in diesen letzten
tagen dass man sagt man man kann da
nochmals umdrehen
das ist durchaus möglich man kann nicht
mehr die grundstimmung umdrehen die spd
ist die einstellungen werden auch nicht
mehr geändert haben die frage ist welche
einstellungen rufen die wahlkämpferin
wahlkämpfer in den letzten tagen noch
mal im kopf der menschen wach wir
sprechen dann vom fremming von der
rahmen der politischen entscheidung
zweitstimme und das ist dann die frage
ist das gerahmt als zweitstimme gleich
kanzler stimme das versucht olaf scholz
derzeit auf den wahlplakaten kanzler für
deutschland oder ist zweitstimme
richtung stimme und dann geht es um die
frage wie wird diese regierung
zusammengesetzt und je nachdem in welche
richtung das ausschlägt profitiert die
eine oder andere partei davon die
einzige chance für die cdu es noch
darauf aufmerksamkeit zu lenken und doch
diejenigen die im augenblick aus
enttäuschung über armin laschet erwägen
die spd zu wählen doch wieder
zurückzuholen und das ist nicht völlig
ausgeschlossen
die abstände zu den parteien sind noch
nicht so groß dass es nicht möglich wäre
und welche rolle spielen da die umfragen
und macht es ist es eigentlich richtig
dass man wirklich bis zum schluss dann
nach umfragen veröffentlicht
ja absolut ich bin da anderer meinung
als fraumünster man es gut wenn wir
diese umfragen haben erst recht wenn
sich noch etwas ändert in den letzten
tagen stellen wir uns vor eine woche
vorher hören wir auf die institute
wissen was sich in der zwischenzeit
getan hat die journalistinnen und
journalisten übrigens auch auch die
politiker nur die bevölkerung sollst
nicht erfahren es kommt nicht darauf an
dass wir weniger umfragen haben sondern
dass wir gute umfragen haben und dann
ist das eine neben ganz vielen anderen
informationsquellen die menschen nutzen
und zwar vor allem die die sich
politisch sehr stark interessieren die
viele informationen heranziehen und den
hohe bildung haben leicht manipulieren
lassen die sich nicht da sollte man die
wählerinnen und wähler nicht
unterschätzen ok also das sind sie sich
hier nicht ganz ein jahr wird sie finden
das auch richtig dass man etwas merken
sie was ändert sich dann wenn man das so
kurz vor der wahl dann noch machen also
als meinungsforscherin bin ich natürlich
auch etwas gepasst und der ansicht und
wir haben ja unser unternehmen gegründet
weil ich auch genauer bretschneider sage
das wichtigste was wenn man den
politischen diskurs rhein geben können
sind valide informationen und die sind
einfach eine ergänzende informationen
zur meinungsbildung wir kennen alle die
effekte die umfragen haben können es
gibt diesen effekt dass man mit dem
gewinner nach hause gehen möchte eben
auf den stärksten setzen möchte es gibt
aber auch eine gegenläufige effekte das
noch gleicht einer kleineren parteien
noch über eine 5 hürde helfen möchte wie
groß die einzelnen effekte sind das
lässt sich schwer messen und
da komme ich wieder zurück zu der
ansicht dass es einfach ein weiteres
informationsangebot ist was einfach gut
sein muss es müssten einfach weil die
daten seien und sind deshalb vielleicht
auch eine gute ergänzende quelle zu
facebook kommentaren gesprächen an der
supermarktkasse gespräche in der familie
herr llambi nach ihrer beobachtung jetzt
wieder die beobachtung der
kanzlerkandidaten wie wichtig werden
diese umfragen gesehen ist das ein punkt
an dem man sich wirklich orientiert oder
ist es ja die twitter- botschaften oder
was haben sie so bemerken und wann
werden wann wird man nervös in den
parteizentralen
also die werden enorm registriert einige
sind geradezu süchtig nach den
umfrageergebnissen nachdem zwischen
werden ich nenne ihnen ein beispiel
beobachten gerade alle wie die union
eine große wahlkampf improvisationen
betreibt auch aufgrund dieser umfrage im
frühjahr ist man davon ausgegangen
dass die grünen der große
ernstzunehmende gegner sind also in
einem duell dann hat man sehr späten
viel zu spät gemerkt nein ist die spd
die auf eine umfrage nach vorne
geschossen ist da war man nicht darauf
eingestellt hat kein rezept und den
april das war in der zeit als armin
laschet und markus söder diesen
machtkampf ausgefochten haben und amen
lasset
dann kanzlerkandidat wurde habe ich ihn
gefragt was für eine art wahlkampf
erwarten sie wird das ein lagerwahlkampf
und er sagte damit kann da gar nichts
anfangen und möchte auch nicht
polarisieren unter anderem aufgrund der
umfrage veränderung und dramatischen
verschiebungen zu ungunsten der union
beobachten wir jetzt wie armin laschet
das gar nicht wollte ein lagerwahlkampf
führt also der in den letzten tagen vor
allem darauf selbst angst zu schüren für
vor rot grün rot das ist ganz wesentlich
auf die immer schlechter werdenden
umfragewerte für die union
zurückzuführen und denken sie dass das
verfängt
das werden wir am nächsten kommt
wozu socken wahlkampf von 1994
dabei die pds
der verfängt nicht mehr so
auch weil viele spüren dass die spd und
die grünen nicht wirklich mit den linken
koalieren wollen sondern viel lieber
eine ampelkoalition mit der fdp
anstreben aus vielerlei gründen
dafür gibt es zahlreiche signale und aus
der koalition strategischen und
verhandlungs strategischen gründen
schließen beide parteien eine koalition
mit den linken nicht aus aber das ist
nicht mehr das schreckgespenst wie 1994
fraumünster man wie wichtig ist es dass
man im wahlkampf dass man den eindruck
hat als bürger da kämpft jemand wirklich
also das heißt ja nun mal wahlkampf und
irgendwie nicht einfach hier war
gespräch oder so also wie wichtig ist
das dass man das gefühl hat da steht
jemand dahinter und da ist auch sichtbar
also auch die menge an plakaten oder
haustür wahlkampf all diese klassischen
dinge das sehen wir jetzt dass die
diskussion wird armin laschet überhaupt
plakatiert sieht man den überhaupt auch
in der eigenen partei geführt wird und
auch in der öffentlichkeit geführt wird
und ich glaube was man bei ihm lange
vermisster ist genau dieses kämpfen und
zwar auch als motivation für die vielen
die an den marktplätzen stehen vor
supermärkten die zettel verteilen die an
haustüren klingeln weil die wollen
motiviert sein und wenn dann einer sagt
ja im schlafwagen hat er nicht gesagt
aber auch das kriege ich schon irgendwie
ich merke mich da so durch durch den
sommer dann hat entschieden nicht
funktioniert ich glaube bei ihm hat man
gemerkt mit dem ersten trial da war klar
wo ich bin so in der defensive ich muss
wirklich angreifen auch wenn das
eigentlich gar nicht wieder meine
absicht war noch mein naturell ist das
ist nicht sein naturell jeder der ihn
kennt weiß dass ein gewiefter politiker
aber sicher keinen abteilung attacke
mensch ist jetzt muss er das machen und
für urlaubs glaube ich wird es darum
gehen am ende ob die cdu die klassischen
cdu wähler dann doch es schaffen ihr
kreuz bei der spd zu machen weil sie
wirklich olaf scholz so sehr wollen und
ich darauf setzt die union ja noch dass
die dann doch sagen ach irgendwie geht
es nicht mit der spd ich kreuze doch
anders an aber wenn das nicht gelingt
dann reißt er kanzler mit der
rote-socken-kampagne sozusagen also
jetzt dass man mir ja in lager war man
das unterzieht kann es auch die
gegenteiligen effekt haben weil scholz
ja gerade alles versucht genau das zu
vermeiden er flirtet mit der fdp mehr
als das glaube ich im willy-brandt-haus
irgendjemand je goutieren würde aber das
ist seine art antworten sind sich
schwierig weil wir eben auch nicht
wissen auch wenn jemand stärkste partei
ist ist nicht klar ob derjenige dann
auch den den kanzler stellt wir haben
über die umfragen gesprochen ich würde
gerne auch über dieses phänomen social
media sprechen herr bretschneider wie
wichtig ist das wir haben es gesehen als
der der lacher von laschet der wurde ja
dann ganz schnell übers netz über
twitter und so verbreitet ist das ein
punkt wo man vielleicht einfach noch mal
im wahlkampf anders führen muss und tun
die parteien das klug genug inzwischen
naja social media haben eine wachsende
bedeutung für den wahlkampf der parteien
vor allem erstmal für die mobilisierung
der eigenen anhänger da sind sie
tatsächlich wichtig aber verglichen mit
anderen wahlkampf instrumenten wie etwa
mit dem guten alten wahlplakat ist ihre
reichweite doch zunächst mal begrenzt
unentschiedene wählerinnen und wähler
findet man so nicht so leicht und schon
gar nicht in dem alter segment 60plus
eigentlich auch schon nicht bei 50 plus
wir sehen große unterschiede in der
social media nutzung im wahlkampf die
jüngeren bis 29 jährigen die nutzen
tatsächlich social media plattformen
häufig übrigens auch ganz andere als die
älteren nämlich die bild betonten
instagram und youtube und nicht mehr
facebook und die parteien hecheln da so
ein bisschen hinterher mit
unterschiedlicher geschwindigkeit aber
so richtig verstanden welche dynamik
social media entfalten können glaube ich
noch nicht alle da mehr nach oben
sie möchten gerne
würde gerne frage nach der bedeutung von
sozialen medien beantworten man kann sie
gar nicht hoch genug einschätzen wenn
man kann es an 13 sekunden in diesem
wahljahr festmachen
17 juli und 13 29
lacht armin laschet das unangemessene
lachen und das wäre nicht schlimm
gewesen
es ist nur deshalb schlimm weil wir das
alle gesehen haben und zwar sofort
gesehen haben minuten vielleicht stunden
danach aber wir haben es alle gesehen
vor allem über soziale medien und es hat
sechs stunden gedauert bis sich armin
laschet entschuldigt hat um 18 uhr
26 also sechs unendlich lange im
zeitalter von sozialen medien unendlich
lang
stunden und selbst die leute aus dem
umfeld von armin laschet sagen es gab
einen wahlkampf vor dem lachen und dann
wahlkampf nach dem lachen und das liegt
eben an dieser nicht mehr einzuholenden
situationen das war ein doppeltes
desaster eine katastrophe die
umweltkatastrophe die
flutkatastrophe und natürlich die
politische katastrophe die nicht mehr zu
heilen war hätte man es noch heilen
können also wenn man direkt reagiert
hätte wäre das anders gewesen
grenzen und natürlich die frühe man
reagiert und zwar ganz klar und deutlich
und zwar nicht mit einem
schriftlichen statement sondern indem
man sich vor die kamera stellt und sagt
leut ich sag's mit meinen worten shit
happens ich habe einen fehler gemacht es
tut mir leid ich bin wie ich bin ja auch
mal wieder sagt ich kann mich nicht
verstellen dass es passiert ist tut mir
leid das hätte vielleicht etwas bewirkt
das ist jetzt im konjunktiv aber sechs
stunden zu warten um dann ein
schriftliches statement abzugeben das
geht nicht im zeitalter von sozialen
medien die chance wurde verpasst haben
wir zudem würden sie ist dann wie
wichtig sind die sozialen medien und wie
sehr kann man
ja muss man sich darauf einstellen was
müssen die parteien anders machen also
sechs stunden fand ich gerade mal
beeindruckend weil mir kam es vor wie
eine ewigkeit und das zeigt auch wie
soziale medien eigentlich spielregeln
verändert haben sie greifen nicht für
alle zielgruppen im wahlkampf nur die
älteren und die sind ja auch die
mehrheit der wahlberechtigten in diesem
land werden damit vielleicht weniger
stark erreicht aber andere eben schon
und die können dann vielleicht auch zu
einer stimmungs und wirken
wir erleben schon dass die parteien
mittlerweile sehr viel datenbasierter
arbeiten und auch social media als
möglichkeit zielgruppen zu erreichen
wählerinnen und wähler zu erreichen
nutzen und es ermöglicht natürlich
social media ermöglicht auch die
zielgruppengerechte zu kommunizieren
also ich muss nicht alle mit den
gleichen botschaften ansprechen ich kann
auch botschafter in den einen kanal
geben und botschaft wie in den anderen
dass es leichter als bei wahlplakaten
und deshalb bei den jungen und
funktioniert schon besser wir sehen auch
in den parteipräferenzen auch
unterschiede im social media konsum und
social media als informationsquelle aber
muss ich dann immer wieder vor augen
führen das gros der wahlberechtigten ist
in deutschland über 50 und aufwärts und
die erreicht man dann auch weniger gut
wenn aber jetzt so ein lacher so also so
wichtig ist in so einem wahlkampf und
das alles angeben ändern kann dann
spricht das doch dafür dass es
eigentlich doch mehr um den um den
menschen geht und nicht so sehr um die
inhalte jetzt haben sie ja ebenso die
menschen verbinden bürgerinnen und
bürger vermissen die inhalte aber
fraumünster und wenn ich jetzt auf
diesen lacher coco oder auch diese sache
mit frau berbalk und die ihren umgang
mit ihrer biografie dann spricht das
doch eher dafür dass die dass die
bürgerinnen gucken was ist das für ein
mensch was hat der film charakter also
die diese klassische frage wurde ich von
dem ein auto kaufen naja ich glaube
würde ich mich von dem regieren lassen
16 jahre lang hat jemand regiert frau
merkel die es am ende ja doch irgendwie
geschafft hat immer oder zumindest
meistens auf dem platz eins der
beliebtesten politiker zu bleiben und
doch ist gallarate
die also schon auch nur in stil geprägt
hat und ich glaube bei aller kritik an
ihr inhaltlich an vielen punkten ist es
doch etwas angenehmes was sie irgendwie
ausgestrahlt hat in den jahren man kann
jetzt sagen es ist zu wenig gewesen mag
sein aber sie hat eine gewisse ruhe
reingebracht relativ skandalfreier
und ich habe oft danach gehört der der
merkel wäre das nicht passiert mit dem
lacher richtig ist jetzt hat sie auch
zeit gehabt zu lernen aber auch laschet
ist schon lange in regierungserfahrung
und deswegen verwundert es so also er
ist kein politischer neuling und diese
sechs stunden weil sie gesagt haben die
parteien
den nutzen daten und mit um mit social
media umzugehen also da hättest den
gesunden menschenverstand gebraucht sich
genau ebendieser sozialen medien zu
bedienen und sofort zu sagen weil das
geht ja in sekunden war dieses bild
draußen ist ging wirklich um die welt
kann man in dem fall glaube ich sagen
und dann nicht zu schalten und zu sagen
oh gott es war überhaupt nicht
beabsichtigt ich glaube das nimmt ihm
jeder ab war ein fehler das kann man
auch sofort sagen und ehrlich sagen und
genauso wie wie er das denn hinterher
jetzt in ganz vielen interview ist und
auch bayern nie getan hat aber das ist
dem ungewollt genau das ist einfach dann
zu spät es ist ja auch das gesamtpaket
also die bildsprache ist wahnsinnig viel
wert dass haben wir daran gesehen im
negativen aber es haben auch die
positiven bilder gefehlt also laschet
als krisenmanager in den gebieten und
laschet der da ist hilft und das gemacht
hat er hat man sagen ist das fahrrad
sein team das nicht nach draußen gemacht
weil er war ja viel unterwegs hat mit
vielen leuten ja auch wenn überhaupt ist
es nicht gut gelungen und so sieht das
auch die mehrheit der deutschen also er
wurde nicht als starker krisen meine
kleine situation wahrgenommen das ist ja
interessant also das hat herr lang mir
wahrscheinlich besser sagen aber
interessant ist doch schon das in
dokumentationen über olaf scholz ist
irgendwie gelungen ist man sieht im
regierungsflieger gut er ist
regierungsmitglied klar finanzminister
vizekanzler
natürlich hat er diese bilder aber auch
armin laschet hat diese bilder als
nrw-regierungschef auch er fährt in
staatskarossen auch er trifft
entscheidungen auch er war während der
mpk aktiv irgendwie diese bilder hat man
kaum mehr gesehen vielleicht auch aus
angst vor den anderen mpk bildern von
markus söder der dafür auch immer gegen
hielt ich weiß es nicht aber das meinte
ich mit die kampagne ist irgendwie
verloren gegangen im sommer was wäre
denn sinnvoll gewesen helmlampe aus
ihrer beobachtung jetzt weil sie
natürlich auch für die parteizentrale
beobachtet haben und die auch alle
parteizentrale wo man sagt gerade im
umgang mit social media was ist da klug
und oder kann man
kann man sagen krise vorbereitet die
sechs stunden warten übrigens nicht
verrechnet das war nicht 1829 sondern
seine korrektur aber 600 definitiv zu
lang aber nochmals zu der frage die die
vorhin gestellt entscheiden die
wählerinnen und wähler auf grund des
programms parteiprogramm soll aufgrund
der person wenn man sich die
umfragewerte die kurven der letzten
monate anschaue die unter anderem vom
vermieter ermittelt werden dann fällt
auch aufnehmen nur das beispiel der
grünen dass die grünen im april in die
höhe schießen das ist nach einer
personalentscheidung geht es nicht das
parteiprogramm sondern da geht es um die
kandidatin dann wollte sie ein bisschen
ab das war zu erwarten und dann im mai
juni geht es richtig in die tiefe auf
grund vor allem was ist da passiert sind
die panzer der kandidatin passiert die
ganz persönlichen kann
ähnliches bei der union das lief
eigentlich alles ganz gut und ich habe
auch im mai/juni gedacht armin laschet
bundeskanzler bis etwa 2 juli hälfte und
dann muss man die frage stellen was ist
da passiert es gibt das lachen das
parteiprogramm hat sich nicht geändert
das verhalten des kandidaten hat sich
verändert also das wird ob man es mag
oder nicht immer wichtiger und die die
dynamik dieses wahlkampfes ich
wiederhole mich orientiert sich nicht am
parteiprogramm sondern ausschließlich an
der performance der kandidaten aber nach
was herr bretschneider ist ihrer meinung
nach
auf was basieren die wähler und
wählerinnen dann ihr urteil also was ist
das wirklich wahlentscheidende und was
kann man denn da dann als partei
beeinflussen
das ist sehr unterschiedlich je nachdem
von welchem wählerinnen und wählern wir
sprechen ich würde den eindruck dass das
nur personalisierte ist und nur entlang
der kandidaten orientierung entschieden
wird nicht teilen die daten geben das
jedenfalls nicht mehr sondern wir haben
andere wahlen nehmen sie die europawahl
20 19 die stadt voll und ganz unter dem
eindruck des klimawandels und des
protestes von freier software und die
grünen haben ein riesen erfolg
eingefahren oder nehmen sie 2017 als die
afd im bundestag eingezogen ist vor dem
hintergrund des flüchtlings themas
das heißt es gibt wählerinnen und wähler
die orientieren sich etwas mehr an den
kandidaten aber es gibt auch genügend
andere die orientieren sich eher an den
themen und einer partei muss es gelingen
im wahlkampf dass beides
zusammenzuführen themen und kandidaten
müssen zueinander passen in
schwierigkeiten kommen parteien dann
wenn es eine kluft gibt zwischen den
beiden wänden der kopf sagt ich möchte
eigentlich lieber in die partei ickx und
das herz über die kandidaten sagte ich
möchte lieber in die partei hüppes i lon
und dann wird's ein problem in
schwierigkeiten
ich gebe ihnen völlig recht nur wir
stehen doch alle sehr erstaunt vor der
dynamik dieses aktuellen wahlkampf dann
muss man mir erklären warum der so
häufig die richtung gewechselt hat doch
nicht weil die politische großwetterlage
eine andere ist oder war die
parteiprogramme umgeschrieben werden
also die einzige erklärung die ich dafür
habe ist eben das verhalten der
spitzenkandidaten war ja die spd und
herr scholz gerade nicht zusammen passen
jedenfalls nicht so gut also auch wenn
gerade jeder versucht im
willy-brandt-haus zu sagen nein nein wir
waren schon immer gern schaut leider
haben wir auch die basis hatte leider
nichts zum parteivorsitzenden gemacht
also ich stimme ihnen eigentlich zu aber
in diesem wahlkampf habe ich das gefühl
das könnte zum ersten mal ganz anders
sein da passt ein kandidat vielleicht
nicht so sehr zu seiner partei wie die
partei sich das wünscht trotzdem wird er
als sieger oder es zumindest als der mit
den meisten stimmen teilen aus der wahl
hervorgehen und dann gibt es immer
wieder diskussionen auch bayern laschet
wird immer wieder nach den maßen gefragt
sigrid sander passen passen partei und
kandidaten nicht zusammen da geht es
genau um diese frage passt herr maßen in
die cdu oder nicht muss er lasse sich
der distanzieren sind das und da ist ja
eher ausweichend sind das so punkte wo
man sagt ja dann wenn die leute keine
klare antwort geben das wirkt sehr
negativ
sind zumindest symptomatisch für diesen
wahlkampf nutzen ist das quasi wir
feststellen dass da in der union einer
strategie fehlt die fehlende strategie
ordnung führt auch dazu dass man schwer
zuordnen kann wieder eine entscheidung
finale ausfällt und es passt dann ganz
gut ins bild wenn wenn man sich eben
nicht klar positioniert ich wollte noch
eine sache ergänzen ich glaube wir sehen
schon einen sehr stark personen
fokussierten wahlkampf ich glaube das
können wir nicht läuten anhand der
anhand der bewegung die wir haben sich
meine allein in diesem jahr waren alle
drei parteien einmal an erster stelle
also ich weiß gar nicht ob das vorher
schon mal gehabt in dieser in dieser
kurzen zeit
aber es ist eine wahnsinnige dynamik
drin und ich glaube dass diese diese
personen fokussierung die ist ja nur
möglich weil wir jetzt einfach jahr über
jahr einfach eine abnehmende
parteibindung erleben also die menschen
sind weniger einer partei zu haften
weniger an einer partei ist es für sie
leichter auf mein kreuz woanders zu
machen und deshalb haben wir auch
personen überhaupt ist die möglichkeit
auch so viel so viel zu drehen der
politischen und wir hatten vorher wir
hatten so lange angela merkel die sind
zu sagen festgesetzt war und hohe
beliebtheitswerte natürlich hatte dann
war es natürlich auch schwierig dagegen
anzukommen eine sache die ja auch auch
für aufregung gesorgt hat war die war
das video der kinderreporter wo armin
laschet mit kindern gesprochen hat die
aber dann den fragen aufs ohr gegeben
wurden sind von erwachsenen das waren
eben sehr erwachsene fragen auch zum
beispiel bei herrn maßen fraumünster
mann ist das ein punkt wo man sagt das
hat eigentlich das ist eine art des
wahlkampfs oder eines interviews wird
das war einfach nicht fair eigentlich ja
vielleicht hätte nicht erwartet aber ich
wiederhole mich ein bisschen sein team
oder wer auch immer das mal vorher
checken wissen wie genau läuft das
eigentlich und was passiert da und dann
kann man ja auch immer sagen ich mach'
gewisse formate nicht also wenn man das
so nicht erlauben ich glaube das kann
man sich erlauben doch kandidaten sind
so präsent oder man wird halt genau
darauf eingestellt denn wer die wende
und kennt da sitzen kinder die stellen
dir aber ob die jetzt aus den kindern
selber kommen ich glaube auch kinder
haben ein gutes gespür was man fragen
kann wo es wehtut aber vielleicht nicht
so detailliert und wenn das kommt dann
muss sich entsprechend darauf antworten
aber natürlich sitzen kinder vor mir da
muss ich schon drauf eingehen also das
sind so sachen da fehlt es glaube ich
ein bisschen auch an vorbereitung und an
zeit sich auf diese formate einzulassen
und die frage maßen pardon aber das wird
die union ja nach merkel und wenn jetzt
wenn es noch eine niederlage gibt wird
ja die union vor allem die cdu ihren
neuen kurs bestimmen müssen und da ist
dann die frage maßen herbst wo ist
eigentlich dieser konservative flügel wo
von dem man sich so viel versprochen hat
wo war der am 26 september wenn er nicht
noch zum sieg verhilft also sind so
grundsätzliche dinge und da muss halt
einfach eine klare meinung haben die man
auch gegenüber kindern vertreten kann ok
herr bretter sehen sie fanden sie das
jetzt in diesem wahlkampf das so grenzen
überschritten worden sind
ja grenzen werden mal wieder mal
überschritten ich denke zum beispiel
auch an die kampagne der bild zeitung
gegen die grünen und insbesondere gegen
freiburg aber mal ehrlich das ist jetzt
auch nichts neues also kampagnen gegen
willy brandt in den 60er jahren die
waren noch härter die politische
auseinandersetzung teilweise in den 60er
jahren waren noch viel intensiver und
härter ich glaube da halt nur uns so ein
bisschen an punkten auf die im
augenblick vielleicht auch verwöhnt
durch die letzten 16 jahre
herausragend bei erscheinen aber
wirklich raus sind sie nicht sieht man
mal kommt man auch mal auf die social
media zurück sieht man mal von den
hass-tiraden die dort zu finden sind und
das ist wirklich nur neue qualität immer
noch die frage wie viele betrifft das
eigentlich wie viele machen das aber das
was da gemacht wird dann das geht gar
nicht und hat das hat man auch in den
60er jahren mich und es gab zum beispiel
die auseinandersetzung über die plakate
der rechtsextremen die geschrieben
hatten hängt die grünen wo das erste
gericht gesagt hat das ist in ordnung
wenn es 100 meter weg ist von den grünen
jetzt gibt es eine neue entscheidung
dass sie doch abgehängt werden müssen
also das ist ja sind ja schon sehr harte
geschichten oder in nordrhein westfalen
wurde das wahlplakat von armin laschet
wo draufsteht entschlossen für
deutschland stand dann auf einmal
erschossen also das sind ja schon harte
auseinandersetzungen herr llambi würden
sie sagen das ist oder wo gab es ihrer
meinung
nach
grenzüberschreitungen in diesem
wahlkampf ich finde nicht dass das
hauptproblem ist wahlkampf ist eine
schlammschlacht war und ist es geht
nicht um schlamp wenn man im bild bleibt
will der wahlkampf ist versandet und das
ist nicht viel schlimmer weil die
eigentliche debatte dieses jahres und
dieser zeit ist ja welche rezepte haben
die parteien und auch die kandidaten die
kandidierenden was den klimawandel
betrifft und da gibt es gravierende
unterschiede große inhaltliche
politische unterschiede und die wurden
überdeckt durch den wahlkampfstil sowie
wegen gerade beschrieben haben das ist
das dilemma dieses jahres nur um es ganz
kurze machten die union und auch die fdp
setzten viel stärker auf die
selbstheilungskräfte des marktes jetzt
vertrauen im erfindungsreichtum von
unternehmen und die grünen vor allem
auch die spd setzen auf einen stärkeren
staat das ist die eigentliche debatte
die gefüllt werden müsste und die ist
wegen pillepalle oder und mit robert
habeck zu sprechen wegen eines
pustekuchen wahlkampfs nicht wirklich
zur abstimmung geführt worden und
deshalb ist es ein
sehr bitterer ein wahlkampf in dem sehr
bitteren nachgeschmack und
es ist schade dass diese chance zu
vergeben wurde weil ein wahlkampf ist
immer eine große chance für ein land mit
sich selber ins gespräch zu kommen und
vor über haben wir gesprochen die
letzten monate waren
sie mal welche rolle haben die medien
dabei das ist ein pillepalle oder
pustekuchen wahlkampf irgendwie
geblieben ist und dass es zu wenig über
inhalte
medien stellt er immer relativ einfach
ich glaube aber schon dass in dem fall
das hinterfragen wir auch in der
redaktionskonferenz also wir versuchen
schon viele dinge darzustellen so ganz
vielen punkten immer wieder was bieten
die parteien an überblicke
parteiprogramme aussagen von politikern
aber wenn wir jetzt auf klick zahlen
gucken dann wird schon geklickt wie hat
sich laschet geschlagen was hat frau
werk zu ihrem plakat gesagt und so
weiter also da sind wir so eine
tatsächlich ein gewissen kreis und da
kann man sich fragen was ist wenn und
aber ich denke schon dass mit andern
oder mit mit kandidaten mit weniger
fehlern mehr inhaltlicher überzeugungen
und auch weniger wenigkeit persönlichen
miss dritten ist genau diese diskussion
eigentlich hätte geben müssen also die
flutkatastrophe spätestens da und da
wird werden sich auch die grünen wenn es
jetzt so läuft wie es aussieht schon
fragen müssen wie wie kann man aus
diesem sommer nicht rausgehen als sieger
wenn man dieses thema so stark
eigentlich besetzt und dann langsam aber
trotzdem wird nach einem trio wird
gefragt wer wirkte sympathisch und da
wird ja nicht fort wer hat die besten
rezepte gegen den klimawandel also warum
vor dann wird sie wird dann nicht
inhaltliche auch gefragt ja das ist
jetzt wirklich noch frage ich dich jetzt
an die medien zurückspielen kandidat für
diesen fragen ja beauftragen ich finde
auch diese blitzumfragen nach den realen
immer nur bedingt hilfreich weil wir
natürlich auch über alle 33 immer wieder
gesehen haben dass die menschen mit
einer gewissen grundeinstellung
reingehen und diejenigen die in den
wahlumfragen vorne liegen auch stärker
rausgehen
und wohin uns das eigentlich führt in
dieser umfrage sei dahingestellt ich
glaube wir sehen aber in anderen
umfragen dass die menschen schon die
klare erwartungshaltung hatten das klima
wandel ein der großen themen werden wird
und das große thema im wahlkampf und
auch sie ist es für sie auch das zweite
tritt wichtigste thema bei der
stimmabgabe als auch da hätte man aus
einer reinen parteien wirklich sagen
können das besetzen wir in welcher form
auch immer und versuchen eben da auch
wählerinnen und wähler für unsere
inhalte zu begeistern ja bereits schon
wie sehen sie es wie sehr könnte man
versuchen diese inhalte und auch konkret
den klimawandel da als als großes thema
gerade auch für die grünen da noch mal
hoch ziehen jetzt auch vielleicht in
diesen letzten tagen
das wird in den letzten tagen glaube ich
nicht mehr großartig funktionieren wir
haben noch den klimastreit der gibt
nochmal eine aufmerksamkeit für das
thema aber das alleine überzeugt dann
nicht mehr das hätte wirklich früher
passieren müssen glaube auch da war in
der grund anlage des grünen wahlkampfes
zu wenig zuspitzung und zuseher der
versuch in die große mitte der breiten
gesellschaft rein zu kommen
auch mit teilweise weichgespülten
aussagen das thema aber doch
funktionieren können sieht man ja ein
stück weit bei olaf scholz der ist ja es
auch nicht als supermann in diesem
wahlkampf gegangen sondern naja halter
olaf scholz und das thema soziale
gerechtigkeit das ist im wahlkampf mit
ihm zusammen wichtiger geworden in der
wahrnehmung und da die spd was nicht
viele wählerinnen und wählern glaubhaft
das angebot kommt ihr zugute zwei jahre
lang hat das
konnte niemand versteht also mindestlohn
12 euro versteht jeder das ist ja dann
auch okay machen wir ganz kurz zum
schluss frau münstermann wer wird
kanzler ich weiß dass ich nichts weiß
nach ihrer beobachtung
ich zitiere die prognose der new york
times haben siebter november 2016 das
war der abend vor der
präsidentschaftswahl nachdem york times
mit einer 85 prozentigen
wahrscheinlichkeit den wahlsieg von
hillary clinton vorher gesagt okay gut
verstehen herr bretschneider sie trauen
sich auch nicht 1 zu nennen
ich denke die weihnachts oder
neujahrsansprache kommt von frau merkel
ok warum der wette würde ich mich fast
anschließen ok dann vielen dank ihnen
hierfür diskutieren und ihnen fürs
zuschauen
[Musik]